what was it like growing up with this
show and growing up on the spotlight
like that it was definitely an education
in all things it was an education and
sex for sure I didn't know what oral sex
was until I watched the show it's taught
me immeasurably like everything I would
have learned over the course of like 30
years I learned in like town that was
sophie turner back in 2017 talking sex
on Game of Thrones
but now she's opening up about her own
sexuality The Game of Thrones star and
her co-star Maisie Williams covered the
latest issue a rolling stone and get
this she told the mag she was preparing
to be single for her whole life until
she met fiance Joe Jonas adding quote I
think once you found the right person
you just know I've met enough guys to
know I've met enough girls to know she
explains a little further what she means
by the girls part of that adding quote
everyone experiments it's part of
growing up I love a soul not a gender
kind of love that a lot of his love his
love is basically what she's saying
there exactly yeah I think the key is to
remember that it's just like every other
relationship and if you're in Hollywood
or if you're in if you're in you know
Africa it's all the same just love and
be loved
of course now she has found love with
Joe and even Maci has noticed a shift in
Sophie since she met Joe as well like
this finished huge growth in you I'm
just really lovely yeah but if you're
wondering if Joe is a Game of Thrones
fan he has to be right
Yeah right well Sophie had this to say
about how the series ends but she played
super coy with et about whether Joe is a
fan I've got a know is Joe rooting for
Sansa to end up on the Iron Throne I
don't know I don't know we didn't talk
about it
um we love blush are you blushing Oh God
yeah or I'm sweaty I can tell Sophie you
look a little smitten right now I don't
know
I'm smitten with Maisie I'm smitten with
Maisie chills my wife so cute
Sophie is currently on vacation in Miami
with her man along with his brothers
Kevin and Nick and Nick's wife Priyanka
and let me tell you it has been a dance
party yeah the Jay sisters in know how
to party
[Music]
Nick even captured this moment them
dancing on a boat to sucker my favor and
get excited you guys it seems like they
are all down there for another Joe bro
video shoot and if it's anything like
the sucker video well infratry
for sure
[Music]
next we'll get to see selfie in the
final season of Game of Thrones
premiering April 14th and I can't wait
to see what sunset is up to now we will
be with sophie turner and her co-stars
in the coming weeks so be sure to keep
it locked to et's youtube for all of
those interviews until next time I'm
Katie Krause and I'm Courtney teza know
bye for now guys
[Music]